[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
it's always fascinating to see how
companies will try new things
to separate themselves from the pack
like there's a lot of great smartphones
out there there's the samsungs and the
apples and the xiaomi's and oneplus
of the world they all have great
performance they all have
pretty solid batteries and overall nice
designs and build quality and some solid
cameras but all these companies they all
know how steep the competition is and so
they need to find
one more thing to give you a reason to
buy their phone
over the rest and so that's where i get
into the classic
feature versus gimmick debate so there's
the high-end flagship smartphone that
also
zooms in a hundred times gimmick or
feature the high-end flagship phone that
also
has a stylus gimmick or feature maybe
the high-end flagship phone that also
has
extra buttons for high-end gaming
gimmick or feature a lot of stuff is
just up to you to decide but now enter
the oppo
find x3 pro the flagship phone
with a microscope
and this isn't a review but this has
been now turning a lot of the same gears
in my head as i've been playing with
this phone
about what really makes a gimmick versus
a feature so the find x3 pro
is absolutely a flagship phone in every
measurable way it's got the snapdragon
8 chip 12 gigs of ram there's 256 gigs
of fast storage inside and you've got a
pretty decent sized
4 500 milliamp hour battery and it's all
packed in
an impressive design so this entire back
of the phone
is one seamless single piece of glass
which is
curved up into this camera module is
pretty cool
and oppo talks a big game about how
difficult this is to do
something like 40 hours to make a single
sheet of glass with this perfect curve
i'd say it's worth it this is the same
reason that i like the s21 series
designs those phones felt very
intentional about embracing the huge set
of cameras
this does the same thing which is very
refreshing versus the typical camera
bump that kind of just looks like it was
stapled to the back of a flat piece of
glass now this mirror finish
you know i probably would have gone with
something a little more matte
or or satin at least myself there is a
blue version that is like a silk blue
anyway this whole body is ip68 dust and
water resistant
and it's pretty slim but also
impressively lightweight so actually it
feels sleek in the hand if you're into
that there's a nice pair of stereo
speakers with dolby atmos support which
is also nice
and up front is a super high-end display
and that's really nice so i don't know
if you're ready for all these numbers we
already know
oppo's done some pretty great displays
in the past see oppo find x2 pro
but this is what a great flagship
display looks like now in 2021
it is a 6.7 inch diagonal with a bit of
a curve around the edges
it's also quad hd plus or 1440p which
lands you at about 525 pixels per inch
that is super sharp and it's 120hz ltpo
panel which means they can actively
adjust the refresh rate up to 120hz
which saves you battery when you're just
reading a webpage or an e-book or
something
like that anything that doesn't need
high refresh rate and it can drop as low
as 5 hertz
but when you are actively moving stuff
and playing games and scrolling around
the ui
the high refresh rate combined with the
240 hertz touch sample rate
makes things feel super responsive so
6.7 inch
1440p 120 hertz ltpo
oh by the way it's an oled too and a
great one at that so this panel is
giving you
1300 nits of peak brightness one of the
brightest on any phone
and that lands it at 5 million to 1
contrast ratio
it's hdr 10 plus certified it covers 100
of the dci p3 color gamut
it's great it checks all the boxes but
let me finish up with the rest of the
flagship stuff
the fingerprint reader is underneath the
glass but it's much lower on this phone
for some reason i'm not sure why like
every other phone i've seen puts it
a few centimeters up from the bottom
where it's more reachable this one
like it feels worse so it's harder to
reach so i'm not sure why it's there
but it's there if you want to use it and
then there is a neat trick in the
software so
a long press on the fingerprint reader
can pull up shortcuts
to some frequently used apps and i love
that that is a really good idea for
software
there's a bunch of other nice stuff like
that sprinkled here in
as you'd expect oppo's color os on top
of android 11.
and i really like what i've been seeing
in color os
over the past two years this might be a
hot take but it's risen
to near the top of my favorite versions
of android to use
period i think i'd put it right above
oneplus oxygen os it's come a long way
and actually a big part of that now is
how the animations and overall physics
of things
move around it's one of those subtle
things you notice when you use a lot of
different phones but it's very snappy
and smooth and responsive there's also
google feed integration on the home
screen
and some better google integration with
some stock apps like the dialer and
messaging
so of course there are still quarks like
there's no quick launch option for the
camera but
other than that it's actually pretty
dope and then of course you can't forget
the charger included in the box in 2021
you actually got to say it
but it's a 65 watt fast charger that can
get you up to 40
percent in 10 minutes which is pretty
sweet but like i said so many other
phones are good now so
sure this phone is excellent but
that's when you get into the world of
unique special features to try to stand
out above the rest of the
also excellent phones sometimes it's
kind of tough to tell if something is
a gimmick or an actually useful
feature or maybe somewhere in between
we'll let you be the judge of that when
you hear about him but i think there are
two things worth noting with this phone
so number one
the billion color display okay so we
know apple has been putting a lot of
care into their displays over the years
they're calling this the first billion
color smartphone
which it's a pretty sexy tagline but
what does it mean
well it means it's a 10-bit display what
they're really saying behind that
billion color tagline is they have a
10-bit display instead of an 8-bit
display and when you hear that it might
not sound all that impressive
but the math on that is so for every
single pixel on an 8-bit display there's
256 different color levels
but in a 10-bit display it doubles that
twice
to 1024. so an 8-bit display which is
pretty common in a lot of smartphones
can show
up to 16.7 million colors
which is awesome but a 10 bit display
can show up to 1.07 billion colors
so there you go it's a billion color
display but that's not actually the
impressive part
there are other 10-bit displays out
there in smartphones the impressive part
of it all
is that they've created a pipeline from
image capture from the cameras all the
way through the firmware to the display
that preserves that 10-bit color so that
extra color information
is super useful in some specific
environments so if you shoot a lot of
photos and videos professionally
especially
you'll always take things like the
higher bit depth to reduce
banding and crumbling and things and
like fades and gradients
so if you're going to be doing a lot of
high level photo and video capture
and then manipulation on this smartphone
display this may be something to care
about but
i'm pretty confident there's going to be
a lot of people who actually get this
phone
who never even noticed this especially
because it is actually turned off by
default you actually have to go into the
display settings
and turn this on if you want to take
advantage of the full 10-bit pipeline so
i think what i'm trying to say here is
there are other more noticeable great
things about this display
like a high refresh rate like the touch
refresh rate
like high brightness that you'll notice
before 10 bit over 8 bit
but if the question is gimmick or
feature
i'm gonna put it in the feature category
it's just a very niche feature just a
very
very
small sliver of people who will actually
take advantage of that
okay then there's the second thing
which is the microscope so this camera
array on the back of the find x3 pro
is already pretty powerful it's using a
new 50 megapixel sony sensor
for both the main camera and the ultra
wide
love that and i think that should be
done more often there's also a 13
megapixel
telephoto 5x hybrid optical zoom but
that's just this little one in the
corner here this last big one
is a three megapixel macro camera
with a ring light around it now okay you
know how i feel about macro cameras
but i should clarify i hate
bad macro cameras like when you see a
like mid-range sort of cheaper phone
slap an extra camera in there to look
like the more premium multi-camera
systems
but it's just a crappy two megapixel
macro that they could have spent that
money on somewhere else in the phone
to make a better difference i hate that
waste of money that's a bad macro camera
but the idea of a good
macro camera well that that could be
kind of fun
now this one is actually a 60x
magnification lens
and the macro bit just means you can get
extremely close as far as minimum focus
distance
and so this is less of a macro camera
and more of a literal microscope so you
open the camera app and switch to
microscope and it flips over to that
camera and when you bring that camera
one to three millimeters from the
subject basically almost touching it
and it works it actually gets
microscope-like images
which means a couple things so the area
you're capturing
is incredibly small and the depth of
field on this lens
is super shallow so this is an f3 lens
and you're you're literally almost
touching the subject so you got to spend
some extra effort stabilizing everything
to actually get a good shot in focus
but the photos you get are crazy i
actually just made up this game so
you can play along it's like a game show
i'm going to show you
the super macro photo and then you can
try to guess what it's a picture of
i'm convinced you're going to get all of
them wrong or you probably won't know
what i'm taking a photo of but
pause it if you need more time let's
play a little game
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so how would you do one or two right
maybe i think the dollar bill one maybe
was the the one that more people will
get than not
but just this it's so much fun look at
this look at i just did this earlier
just for fun just see if i can get it to
look at that you can see the threads
on my shirt that's crazy it's so much
fun
okay so the microscope camera
feature or gimmick
okay so it's still a gimmick but not all
gimmicks are created equal and this
is one of the most fun gimmicks that
i've ever seen in a phone it's awesome
like microscopes and macro photography
are hard to do well they're actually
kind of expensive to do well so when
they first started showing up in phones
they were usually so
trash because they were using a smaller
cheaper sensor
and they would get a cheap lens that
doesn't let in very much light so
you have this poor noise performance and
not a lot of detail
pretty bad combination and macro photos
would look like garbage
but they did that because well it's more
expensive to make a good macro camera if
you remember the dope tech video i did
about the pro blends which is another
crazy macro capable lens that lens had
an f14
to f40 aperture range but you'd strap
that to a much bigger sensor
and there's a bright ring light attached
to the front of it and
this is a 1500 lens so this this
microscope camera to me
feels like oppo actually put extra time
and effort and money into making a much
better than average experience and it
shows
the f3 aperture is interesting but
obviously the ring light because you get
so close to your subject you cast a
shadow on it
so they really thought about a lot of
this stuff now if this is going to go
from
gimmick to feature one of the biggest
differences between a gimmick and a
feature is
iterating and keeping going with it
making a new version maybe this
can benefit from dual aperture in the
future where you have like an f8
version that gets more in focus but
that's all getting ahead of myself
this is one of the most fun gimmicks
i've ever seen in a phone
and i'm glad they did it either way
that's about it
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace